and look who gets the handout the  Writing Awards a Hoboken dropout  auntie rose Lee's mother well go ahead  Rose arise children are good we learned  to talk for Best Screenplay based on  material from another medium the  nominated writers are James Goldman the  lion in winter Neil Simon The Odd Couple  then in Harris Oliver Stewart Stern for  Rachel Rachel and Roman Polanski  Rosemary's Baby the winner and the  winner is  James Gold  I've been told by people who have been  through this experience that the smiles  of joy that appear occasionally up here  don't come from joy at all but sheer  relief and it's absolutely true and I  can't tell you how relieved I am